ce qu'il ya eu beaucoup aux coudres à
quai pendant ces neuf ans oui je suis
restée pour le lance regarder avant de
rater ses parts à les salariés ben voilà
c'est la balle avec nous ce soir gad
elmaleh la fiche des seigneurs et
bientôt deux millions d'entre deux
millions d'autres ça c'est une belle
expérience
bah oui ça j'avais des cheveux bizarres
dans ce
j'ai expliqué
[Applaudissements]
tout à l'heure
et je me battrai
les cinq allemands rentrer chez eux donc
de ces jeunes voient la télé mais sur la
question qu'est ce qui la basse et voilà
c'est noël
ce qu'il a montré qu'elle sait il ce
patron bernard les chéris arrêté je ne
sais pas qui a fait ça tout va bien
alors c'est télé ne vaut d'ailleurs été
en régie les chéris qu'est ce qui se
passe s'il vous plaît je n'ai rien fait
rien fait qui fasse je vous jure je
n'avais rien à perdre à moi ça n'est pas
grave on commandée à distance
je vous jure yal'europe code il y aura
d'autres au nom ça n'est pas moi je vous
le jure
regardez comme c'est moi qui a fait ça
voilà là c'est pas moi
c'est pas moi voilà c'est pas moi c'est
pas moi s'il vous plaît mais s'il vous
plaît on se calme ça va aller voir ce
qui se passe en résumé on est là au
chômage la baisse
oh merde
et même quand les mecs qu'est ce qui
s'passe aguilas qu'est ce qui se passe
en régie là haut c'est qui qui qui est
responsable
c'est qui non c'est parce que j'ai pas
testé en fait question qu'est ce qu'il
ya je n'ai pas fait exprès en fait parce
que du stagiaire bras le cou et on a dit
il faut valoriser les maîtres de la
lumière mais métier mais c'est
magnifique mais j'adore laurent baffie
qu'est la notion d'amour élèves et on a
dit de tu fais un petit coup de main tu
fais ce que tu veux toi tu venir avec
mon bateau tu veux rester ici n'a pour
l'instant faut que je me familiarise
parce que je voudrais pas envoyé de la
mousse sur les gens d'accord alors dans
le fond que j'apprenne justesse qu'on
peut donner un micro à laurent baffie tu
peux intervenir quand tu veux dans
l'émission avec tu veux dire tout ce que
tu veux je t'aime ou non de changer ça
va commencer
[Applaudissements]
laurent batik et avec nos
applaudissements pour les bravo merci
dirrell regarder ces lions de cannes qui
se cachent mal aux yeux
ces déchets
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ce soir laurent baffie
[Applaudissements]